if you want a life of purpose we can by
inverting the notion that everything
happens for a reason all your efforts
personal professional carnal you must be
willing to make the hard choices do the
unpleasant things risk your most
valuable passes because nothing
worthwhile is ever achieved without
sacrifice
[Music]
now that you're on the brink of
greatness I are there still limitations
to what you'd be willing to sacrifice in
this case a night alone with your
husband would that be an acceptable
condition of a firm offer to finance
your company what do you really know
about a Montgomery
things could get dangerous very quickly
things have always been dangerous
what is it that you imagine I did him I
made a mistake I do not deserve to lose
everything regret is all I felt since
the moment we met how many more people
need to be heard before you got what you
want you're more committed than you
realize the worst kind of victim is the
one that chooses to create another
[Music]
are you absolutely certain this is the
choice you want to make I'm not what you
think I am maybe not now I'm beginning
to see potential
success comes at a cost
[Music]
you
you